deutlich wird ich würde vielleicht doch
lieber
er wird
lol
rtr
befürchtet wird
so 18
Schalke 04 sofort die Wackener 5 504
dort ist
Take
viele Fragen
und ich finde die Zinsen sind war ich
bin eigentlich kein klassischer
Zeichentrick John Key
um in mehrerlei manchen Sachen
regelmäßig schwach unter anderem bei 1
ins Netz insofern Prozent finde ich das
was ich da sehr wenig im Sinn
Grundstücke stehen
der immer selben Boot
Mas fast noch mehr eigentlich an den
Texten nicht als Prozent ein Ereignis
gemacht ist
die Texte sind und bleiben das beste was
ist das was es gibt
kann ich ganz ganz froh dass ich solche
Sachen sagen darf weiter auf die
Marxheimer sagt dann macht es ist schon
toll das ist ein großer Glücksfall
sehr interessant es ist der letzte Teil
der Frage inwiefern
an das auch Einfluss darauf hat um mim
einen eine Sache findet
Prozent
gemäss dem Spielplan in der Nacht oder
befragt wird
das wäre er fast aus wie ein paar
Szenen dass er fast so was wie ein will
Verbands Gespräch einem
Bewerbungsgespräch Situation
dass man sagt ich Prozent erkenne dich
selbst aus wenn nicht und geht wenn er
zu einer freien Stelle sehr leicht
beantworten damit in den Job haben
das wäre da nicht die falsche
Herangehensweise wenn man danach
besetzen würde das gilt fürs
Schauspiel wie für synchron und es gilt
eigentlich für
für die meisten Clubs
von Mikrofon oder vor der Kamera
möcht ich mal sagen
das nicht der den Job kriegt der am
meisten weisen ein Format
oder in ein Auto oder über ein
nun ca
sondern der der es dann am besten machte
am besten drauf passt
sowas dann glaube ich bei mir hat das
sich genommen wurde weil Prozent ich
mich stimmlich am besten alles Original
Prozent anpassen konnte annehmen konnte
weil es sehr wichtig war nach Ende der
Fahrt Manns Tod
wie war das für alle
eine ganz schwere Situation
für die Macher für die Fans
für mich sowieso auch
insofern um
und kann nicht die Frage beantworten
wer am besten drauf passt sich den Job
was ist deiner Band auch so wenn einer
Meißner e-gitarre zusammenbaut aber
nicht so gut spielen kann wird der in
der Band nicht mitspielen ist wird der
mitspielende am besten spielt
hier muss dann
die Medica Capotes die zu dem guten
getan Bauer bringen